hi I'm Scott Adkins an actor and a
martial artist and this is training
support at tipsy like Jenga asks how do
MMA fighters take kicks to the shin I
stubbed mine and I'm TKO'd by the coffee
table ha I know the feeling every time
that I've been away and made a movie for
a few months I come back and I start
training again and it hurts heel kick in
the Thai pads without your trousers on
it takes a while to get used to it and
also if you don't do it it feels like
your shins to quickly become like butter
again so Thai pants are what Thai boxers
use mostly for kicks their long pants
like this that you slip your whole
forearm into it and they're great for
hitting with round kicks and then for
the body you can hold them against your
body and so you punch them and you kick
them but they're very tough material
made out of leather it takes a while to
get used to kicking those with a bare
shin went when you're a beginner just
kicking the the Thai pants will make
your shins much harder but there are
other ways to harden them up like
rolling sticks and kneeling on beer
bottles and all sorts of stuff like that
but the truth is nothing can prepare you
for how much it would hurt when you kick
someone in the shin as hard as you can
with your shin in a fight the adrenaline
is going to stop you feeling it but
you're gonna feel it the next day at
alan rodriguez 9 asks question for
martial artists should i ever let a
potential attacker know that you are
trained in martial arts in this country
the UK it was said that if you were an
expert in martial arts and you didn't
warn the potential attacker that you're
about to strike you can actually be in a
lot of trouble in a UK course of law I'm
not even sure if that still exists
anymore but I do know this story of a
black belt Taekwondo instructor from the
UK who was in a pub and he was getting a
bit of grief off someone and he said to
the guy listen I must warn you that I'm
a black belt in Taekwondo and then he
got knocked out spark just after he gave
in a warning so my advice to you is
probably keep it a secret surprise is is
all part of being a good fighter never
start a fight but if you are sure if you
are positive
that there's no way out and you can't
talk your way out of this situation and
that it's gonna go down just keep it a
secret and not the other guy out at RZA
Wow that's the real RZA that's brilliant
kick-ass Friday what movie do you think
has the best fight scene ever
great question RZA obviously I've seen a
lot of martial arts films as I'm sure
you have as well one of my favorite
fights is from they live the John
Carpenter film with Roddy Piper
I love the extended fight scene that
they have in the middle of the movie
when Roddy Piper is trying to get Keith
to put the the shades on and he doesn't
want to put the shades on and it's a
great fight because it's not about the
choreography it's not about how well
it's shot it's really about this battle
of attrition where one guy is trying to
get the other guys to do something and
the fight just goes on and on and on and
it doesn't stop and then you think it's
gonna end and it keeps going and it
keeps going and the way they perform it
is brilliant and it's got those funny
moments in there that is one of my
favorite fight scenes it's hard to say
that's my favorite fight scene but
certainly that is one of my all-time
favorite fights they live at get a grip
Jim possibly stupid question for Jim
Nast's when you twist in your tumbling
do you have to spot something like you
do in a turn you do have to spot not
only in gymnastics but also in martial
arts if I'm gonna throw a spinning kick
before I throw the kick I need some
ahead all around and spot my target that
I see who or what I'm gonna kick before
I kick it you don't be kicking blind and
the same thing with gymnastics with like
a straight back somersault with a twist
you go up you get the height first
wherever the head goes the body will
follow
- you twist your head you need to see
the floor so that you understand where
it is that you can land there one of the
things you need in in gymnastics and
also martial arts is spatial awareness
you know one of the things you need to
do is spot at Shelley 2:39 boxing or
kickboxing question which stance has an
advantage Orthodox or southpaw and isn't
worth knowing both it's generally
thought that a southpaw has the
advantage over an orthodox fighter so an
orthodox fighter is going to be someone
who
right handed lime a and you're gonna
stand with your right hand back this is
the power side maybe your right leg is
the power side typically a left handed
person so he's going to stand the other
way in the power hand is going to be the
left most people are right handed so if
you take your average gym the majority
of people that are training in that gym
are going to be right-handed
it stands to reason that the southpaw
the left-handed guy is going to have
more experience fighting a right-handed
guy but to answer your question it's
definitely worth understanding and
knowing how to fight in both stances and
to be able to throw strikes from the
Orthodox position and a southpaw
position and what I try to do as an
orthodox fighter is our switch stance
just before throwing a strike and if
you're dealing with someone that's not
very versed in that type of thing they
have to readjust and in that split
second maybe that's just enough time
hits him with some strikes that he
doesn't see coming because you change
your stance and your camera from her
from a different perspective at Nikoli G
asks question for martial artists
Crescent kicks straight leg or chamber
for those of you who don't know a
crescent kick is where I would bring up
my knee you can either do an outside
Crescent kick with the outside of the
foot or you can do an inside Crescent
kick with the inside of the foot it's
called a Crescent because it moves
either inwards or outwards you need to
chamber the leg if you throw a straight
leg for me that's going to be much
slower than if you begin the movement
with a bent knee what I like to do with
the Crescent kick and with the hook kick
is I like to chamber the knee and hold
my foot in so that I can kick faster or
swing through faster and then at the
last minute I like to flick it out so it
comes out very loose almost like a
flicking motion it works perfectly with
a hook kick but also I think for the
Crescent kick you should bring it up
with the knee bent and then flick out
the outside of the foot so that you're
you're hitting with much more torque and
speed I would suggest that if you're
gonna do a Crescent kick you do with the
knee bent at Le madero asks so yesterday
during my training I decided to do the
round kick I want to learn how to
combine the round kick and the uppercut
to follow up the round kick with an
uppercut would
a bit of a strange technique to use it
in my opinion whoo I think you'd be
better served doing a lead up cut
uppercuts off the lead arm and then you
can come through with the round kick now
this is technique that I like to do
actually a corkscrew uppercut so you got
your standard uppercut which is just
coming straight up but the corkscrew
uppercut it comes out a bit a bit
further you twist up but as I can as I
do it I step off the center line so I'm
hitting my opponent but I'm stepping off
this way and what I'm doing is I'm
stepping across the line of his body and
I'm opening up his body to a lovely
round kick to the body or even a round
hit to the head step across on the
outside of his leg and throw that round
kick into the midsection naturally you
see Conor McGregor do this punch a lot
the corkscrew uppercut he sort of jumps
forward and to the side as he throws it
and he gets closer to his opponent and
he can hit them with her with one of his
powerful left strikes at and Melissa
Heist okay kickboxing question round
kick to the head is it okay to make
contact with the foot instead of the
shin the shin gets me into damn close
well I know what you're saying Melissa
you don't want to be too down close if
you can kick him in the head with the
shin that's preferable to the foot
because the shin is much harder and
certainly if you're kicking to the body
into the leg you don't want to catch
them with your foot because what you can
do is sometimes bends your foot back
even break your foot and in some cases
that happens a lot so if you can kick to
the head and hit them with your shin
that's going to be preferable to the
foot but still the foot is going to do
the job should you hit them hard enough
and they don't see it coming at rim the
human asks can you teach me how to
properly drop kick and the answer is no
because I'm stuck here on my chair with
these it might be my ears I don't
actually know what what you mean by drop
kick perhaps you mean the axe kick
really what you need for an axe kick is
to be very flexible so that you can
bring your leg all the way up and then
of course you're going to contract your
hamstrings when it gets to that height
and bring your heel down on your
opponent's head you need to be flexible
it's very easy to pull your hamstring if
you're not warmed up because as soon as
you get to the height in your hamstring
is fully strengths you're going to
contract
and you're gonna bring the heel down on
the guy's head
hopefully it's a good kick at Jameson F
I'm contemplating starting at home
kickboxing training any recommendations
yes just then I recommend that you go to
my youtube channel everyone was always
asking me to do kicking tutorials so I
recommend you go to the Scott Adkins
official YouTube channel you will be
able to learn some kicks from Scott
Adkins himself what a plug what a plug
the Graham 27 asks how do you split your
week between martial arts training and
lifting weights frankly I'd die I'm
adding up there I think that's what he
meant for a body like boy cos muscle
mass and martial arts don't go hand in
hand it can slow you down yes you'll be
stronger you'll be more powerful but
it's also a lot more weight to carry
around and you'll probably gas out
quicker
obviously I make movies and people
expect you to look a certain way the
first time I played boy car I was
opposite Michael Jai White is a big guy
so I wanted to put on as much muscle
mass as I could the way I'll split up
the week is I will normally wait train
on a Sunday and a Monday and then on a
Tuesday I'll do my martial arts
Wednesday and Thursday I'll do some more
bodybuilding weight training and then on
Friday I'll do martial arts and then I'm
gonna have Saturday off that's typically
how I split up the week four days of
weight training and two days of martial
arts but if I'm going to do a film
there's more martial arts heavy or if I
want to be a bit lighter on the feet
I'll probably up the martial arts and
cardio training and a bit less on the
resistance trainer at yoga tomo this
knee injury has slowed down my entire
existence
how did Boykin manage to 180 degrees
spin into an extended knee block that
caused the Columbian boot shin to snap
in two
I know you're coming from me listen I
tore my ACL in my left knee it took me a
good year to get back to normal actually
I tore my ACL and then I had to do three
films Universe soldier I did el gringo
and then I did the Expendables - all
with no ACL I don't know how I did it by
the time I got to do Expendables 2 it
was a winter in Bulgaria every morning I
woke up in agonizing pain but I just had
to get on with it and throw kicks at
Jason Statham when I did get this
surgery done I had to take at least nine
months off of full contact and I had to
rehab it as best as I could so if you've
got knee problems made what it suggests
is that you really need to build up the
muscles around the knee that are going
to hold that in place the stronger your
leg is the stronger your knee is gonna
be if you can build up to doing piston
squats which is where you have one leg
up in the air all your weights on on the
bad knee and you can go all the way down
to the bottom and push yourself all the
way up to the top on one leg then you
know that your knee is gonna be fixed
yeah and boy can manage to do it I don't
know just wanna graft at Tom con em ty
Scott how did you build so much mass to
blade Boyka but stay so agile did you
train like a bodybuilder to gain mass
actually yeah I did train like a
bodybuilder to gain mass when I was
first starting my weight training
journey I had the Joe Weider
encyclopedia which you know things have
changed since then but I've still kept
the those principles of bodybuilding
really if you want to add muscle to your
frame you need to be putting your
muscles into progressive overloads you
need to keep lifting heavier weight in
order to put muscle on to your frame but
you're right it was very difficult when
I did the first Boyka movie and the
reason I wanted to put the muscle mass
on was because I'm the bad guy and
Michael Jai White's the good guy and he
was so much bigger than me I really
wanted to put on as much muscle as
possible because I just felt like it
wasn't gonna be enough of a threat I
wouldn't be able to intimidate him if I
was as you know nor me so I put on as
much muscle as I could over the course
of six months yeah it was a lot of
pressure on the joints obviously Boyka
does a lot of
fancy kicks he's very agile so if you're
doing a back somersault and you're
carrying around an extra six kilograms
of muscle it certainly you feel it on
the knees you feel it on the back you
feel it everywhere it's a lot harder but
back then I was 27 and I was a beast and
somehow managed to keep all the kicks
that I was doing and then up my game and
learn some even crazy ones and still
carry around that muscle mass but it's
not easy and it's a young man's game
okay so that's it thank you Twitter for
all your questions and thank you wired
for letting me give you some martial
arts training support